a lot of companies out there that offer continuous glucose monitors with an app for your phone
like kc means levels and mark time and function or something do you have an opinion on these
programs in general or recommend one they're expensive but maybe if maybe if done for a few months
can lend some insights and individual blood sugar effects of foods um yeah i mean if you have a
continuous glucose monitor as people that are diabetes but at times they're insurance will pay
for that you could use that um do and i think you need to do i think you need to be that obsessed with
your glucose levels if you are not diabetic no i don't think you need to be that obsessed with
your glucose levels but like i said before it's the goal of a cancer patient to get their glucose
levels down into the 80s or 70s that would be optimal that you're going to have the optimal
starvation of a cancer if your glucose levels are in the 70s i don't think you need to get
into a ketogenic state where you're only burning ketones in order to starve a cancer
but for a lot of people especially if you're a little older it's almost impossible to get into
ketosis into true ketosis even if you're completely a hundred percent on a ketogenic diet
so um because there's issues with insulin resistance over time where your cells have been
damaged the cell membranes are replicating cells with damaged cell membranes and you could never get
into that state and people have issues um especially as we age you know if you have we don't
for a 22-year-old patient with brain cancer going on a ketogenic they probably get into ketosis
if they're strict other diet in a very short period of time people that are older stay in
on a very strict almost ketogenic diet can sometimes can never get into ketosis why is that because
the cell membranes are are just never healthy enough to do that so um even by doing everything right
some people are like i do everything right i don't eat any carbs i stick on a very strict diet
and they can't seem to budge their glucose below 90 um and they're on burberry they'd probably
abicolidate and everything that you can think of that would be possible to help lower glucose levels
and they still can't get it lower and it's because of multiple factors but it's mainly
your health of the of the cell membranes that is probably never going to change for that person
so um do you need a continuous glucose monitor no i don't think so and i don't recommend that you
should be taking your glucose levels every morning either you don't need to be obsessed about it
ultimately with with your diet with your cancer protocol you want to do everything you can to do
what's right and ultimately have to rest and leave it the results to god there is a level of trust
and faith involved in healing involved in everything we do i mean do i you know have a you know
do i use precaution when i drive home at work of course i do do i turn my lights out what it's
a little bit at dusk but certainly not dark yeah i do because it's the wise thing to do so you make
wise decisions and i always drive on the correct side of the road you're making wise decisions
but to my obsessed and worried and and making it spending too much time and too much energy and
too much created too much anxiety in my life over certain things like in this case
getting my glucose levels down with it not necessarily in a state of active cancer um then then you
have to say that my level of anxiety over this thing could be the cause of
and you know increase cancer growth so you have to keep that balance in life so you know even
when i was at my worst and my health was at its worst and i thought for sure that i only had a couple
months left on this earth no matter how hard it is you have to rest in the fact that we serve
a sovereign god he is holy he is good i will do everything on my part within reason once i cross over
that imaginary line of obsession uh in trying to gain health and that line is in a different place
in everybody's life but we have to be careful not to cross that line where where health and healing of
this disease is becomes idolatry then it's unhealthy and then the anxiety that we have
that we are undergoing and doing so can be actually a driver of my cancer so um that's hard
that's hard for everybody and and i'm not here telling everybody where that line is in their life
i think you should keep trying to keep asking and keep trying to figure this out
you know just you know just give up and and die but you but you also
how you get to a point where i'm trusting god and knowing that you know i'm resting in him too
and i'm that's we're having that relationship with him is so important that you can ask him
Lord tell me how far to go here tell me what i should do it's like asking that question
should i buy another machine should i do another program should i do this you tell me where to go
i want to be obedient above all things and that's the uh that's the most important thing my most
important thing is to die and get to have it in here well done with faithful servant not hey you
were lazy and you didn't do everything you should have done nor hey you were obsessed with something
and made an idol out of something that you shouldn't have either so that everybody is that you
got to find that balance the only way i know to find that balance is to have that relationship with him
that um i can hear his holy spirit tell me uh uh uh uh or yes yes yes yes yes yes and um that's
different for everyone that's that that's what a personal relationship is and that is my biggest
piece of advice for all of you don't trust everything i say don't trust everything you read on the
internet for sure don't trust everything your oncologist says are absolute and but all the believe you
have to trust um what the Lord has said to you so read his word to know that you can hear his voice
so that you know that uh no my Heavenly Father wouldn't say that you know i just know that i know
him well enough because i studied his word enough that he wouldn't tell me to do that but it's that
still small voice that you need to be able to hear um his yays and nays uncertain subjects that aren't
necessarily written in scripture so have a that relationship so that you know what to do that's my
biggest advice for you and it will never end